[Música]
me invitaron a contarle un poquito de
esta historia de innovación en educación
en esta foto como pueden ver estoy yo
chiquita como cuando estaba creo que en
quinto básico no le pedí permiso a mis
amigos del colegio les dio disculpa por
poner esta foto me van a matar después
compañeros del colegio y estábamos en
septiembre si pueden ver estamos con la
ropa de 18 de septiembre que falta poco
la traje de cueca y durante mi educación
en el colegio tuve altos y bajos
entre esos altos y bajos el hecho de que
mi nombre era diferente era razón de
bullying o inclusive el hecho de mi
color de piel o el hecho de ser
vegetariana que antes no estaba de moda
y ahora más o menos sí pero en esa época
no estaba tan de moda tu esposa altos y
bajos pero el que más impacto en mi
educación
mis sueños en donde sonaba soñaba con el
futuro no igual que los supersónicos
soñado en el futuro no los drones
etcétera y otra de las cosas que me
impactó y que cambió mi educación no fue
un texto escolar o sea no fue la página
245 de ese texto escolar sino que fue
una profesora no una profesora que me
inspiró a ver las cosas una forma
diferente una profesora que me ayudó a
experimentar y ver el mundo que nos
rodea una profesora que me habló de
científicos
y de la historia de los científicos por
ejemplo algunos que vemos acá en
pantalla pueden reconocer algunos aquí
pueden reconocer algunos acá
a quien reconocen
einstein sí a quien más reconocen por
niels bohr bien está max planck ni
sports muy bien muy bien aquí las pocas
mujeres la única mujer en esta foto de
la reunión de los científicos y también
me hablaron de científicos chilenos como
el profesor pablo valenzuela o maría
teresa ruiz no sólo pablo valenzuela
descubrió que el virus de la hepatitis y
desarrolló la vacuna recombinante contra
el virus de la hepatitis b se dio
bioquímica y saber de estos científicos
me inspiró a estudiar bioquímica pero
durante mi educación científica mucho de
lo que se pasaba en la universidad e
inclusive en el colegio era muy teórico
y mucha fórmula es de iguales mejora es
decir ustedes alguna vez
lee aprendieron cómo aprendieron a andar
en bicicleta
se cayeron sí bueno mi papá también
cuando me enseñó andar en bicicleta no
me enseñó a andar en bicicleta leyendo
un libro sino que me enseñó viviendo la
experiencia andar en bicicleta donde uno
se cae él fracasa aprende y nuevamente
vuelve a intentar igual que en la
ciencia para aprender ciencia uno tiene
que vivir la experiencia de experimentar
y ver el mundo que te rodea de caerte
pero lamentablemente para hacer eso
muchas veces uno necesita equipos de
laboratorio y en latinoamérica 88% de
las escuelas no tienen laboratorios
según el banco interamericano del
desarrollo y los que tienen equipos de
laboratorio no los utilizan y aquí en
algunos ejemplo los costos del
equipamiento de laboratorio
y no solamente eso si ustedes ven los
resultados de pizza los países del
caribe y de latinoamérica estamos al
final y si uno analiza lo que dice el
bid y otros reportes para poder alcanzar
a los países de la usb en algunos países
que se están generando cambios uno
necesita entre 20 a 30 años para generar
y alcanzar esos países mientras que hay
otros que no están generando cambios y
sin alcanzable brasil méjico chile
nuestro país entonces le hago la
pregunta si tenemos este problema
multicausal no que el equipamiento de
laboratorios costos y los profesores
necesitan apoyo no muchas veces están
sobrecargados de trabajo los obligamos
con las mallas curriculares de pasar el
contenido los estudiantes no están
motivados no nos fomentamos la
curiosidad entonces que podemos hacer la
pregunta es entregamos más textos
escolares más libros
rellenamos los colegios con laboratorios
y equipamientos de millones de dólares
cómo podemos fomentar el aprendizaje de
la ciencia cómo podemos democratizar la
ciencia y cambiar la manera en que se
enseña ciencia y fomentar la curiosidad
para que nuestros estudiantes no se
desmotiven y no le tengan miedo a la
ciencia
por primera vez en la historia de la
humanidad tenemos un instrumento masivo
que tiene más poder computacional que el
primer computador que llevó el hombre a
la luna hoy día y más de 4 billones de
smartphones en el mundo y muchos no
saben pero de seguro aquí muchos saben
son muy smart haga que estos celulares
los dispositivos móviles tienen una
serie de sensores que se utilizan
normalmente en juegos y navegación o me
sacó una self y llamo lugar pero no para
educación científica y lo que nosotros
hacemos y tomamos todos estos sensores
la cámara el micrófono el acelerómetro y
lo transformamos en un instrumento de
laboratorio nosotros empezamos con la
polio para democratizar la ciencia y
cambiar la manera en que se enseña
ciencia y hemos desarrollado algunas app
con una plataforma de aprendizaje y
acompañamiento y capacitación por
ejemplo acá con el laboratorio de física
que los invito a descargar que se llama
la force physics puede realizar
experimentos de física
podemos ver acá un movimiento pendular
aceleración centrípeta aquí los
estudiantes están estudiando la
diferencia
/ distancia y desplazamiento fuerza masa
y aceleración y en química por ejemplo
puedes calcular la concentración de una
solución líquida coloreada a través de
la cámara en nuestro algoritmo sacamos
una foto vemos la intensidad de color y
calcular y no tenemos que comprar un
colorímetro que es más costoso o con un
lente de un dólar que lo adjuntamos a la
cámara podemos tener un microscopio y de
esa manera empoderamos a los estudiantes
a que experimenten y tengan este
laboratorio de bolsillo tenemos estas
tres soluciones innovadoras que son
distintas aplicaciones móviles hoy día
estamos trabajando con el laboratorio de
física que ya ha utilizado por más de
100 mil estudiantes en todo el mundo y
tiene una todo nuestro material tiene
una estructura pedagógica donde
invitamos al estudiante a pensar a
construir a medir a analizar y cost y
concluir
cómo sería una clase tradicional por
ejemplo se acuerdan de la segunda ley de
newton
cómo sería una clase tradicional de un
péndulo es una app o en la pizarra vemos
la fórmula vemos que las vibraciones del
péndulo dependen del largo de la cuerda
analizamos el periodo y aquí está la
fórmula
anótenlo en el cuaderno clase siguiente
como sería ahora si aprendemos
experimentando imagínense que son el
dueño un parque de diversiones aquí en
chile santas y lante
qué pasa si el barco pirata el famoso
barco pirata se estropea o tenemos que
mejorarlo barco pirata funciona con un
como un péndulo tiene un movimiento
pendular no qué haríamos si queremos
mejorarlo si queremos tener más
oscilaciones y a través de la
experimentación con un ejemplo de la
vida real invitamos a los estudiantes a
experimentar con sus dispositivos
móviles y utilizamos la cámara
utilizamos el acelerómetro el micrófono
etcétera y aquí hay algunas fotos de
estudiantes que están experimentando con
materiales muy bajos muy de bajo costo
por ejemplo un cartón una bolsa media el
celular una bolsa de plástico que sale
un millón de dólares y una bolsa de
plástico que queremos reciclar
y aquí tenemos algunos ejemplos de
estudiantes y profesores que nos mandan
estas fotos
de sus estudiantes que están
experimentando hoy día estos estudiantes
han realizado más de 100.000
experimentos en nuestras plataformas y
los mismos profesores están compartiendo
en facebook en su en twitter inclusive
hay grupos de whatsapp y generamos estas
comunidades de práctica con los mismos
profesores y todo esto ha sido posible
gracias a un equipo multidisciplinario
si esa soy yo y el resto del equipo
diseñadores científicos profesores
programadores que han logrado que hoy
día podamos acercarnos a la
democratización de la ciencia pero hemos
tenido sus altos y bajos nuestro camino
ideal o sea va a haber
vamos a cambiar el mundo y vamos a hacer
que todos tengan un laboratorio en el
bolsillo pero en el camino obtenido
muchos desafíos algunas resistencias en
colegios con los celulares poder llegar
a otros países y esto sido un trabajo de
altos y bajos
inclusive nuestros primeros pilotos
recuerdo en un piloto en un colegio que
me tiraron el celular a la cara porque
no querían hacer el experimento y eso
fue hace tres años atrás donde nuestro
diseño no era tan bonito como el de
ahora entonces tuvimos que cambiar
nuestra usabilidad y nuestro diseño de
interfaces para poder satisfacer las
necesidades de los estudiantes y en
estos altos y bajos
debemos decir hoy día que ya tenemos
todos los estudiantes alrededor del
mundo más de 100 mil estudiantes y
nosotros de verdad creemos que el
próximo a stein o la próxima a marie
curie no estará en cualquier parte del
mundo o nuestro próximo pablo valenzuela
o maría teresa ruiz puede estar en una
escuela en el norte de chile en arica o
en el sur en punta arenas o en una
favela en brasil o en un pueblo de
mexico creemos que el talento es
universal pero las oportunidades no y
por eso con la apoyo queremos entregar
esas oportunidades para que todos puedan
experimentar con un laboratorio en el
bolsillo recuerdan esta chica morena
que nación arica no hija inmigrantes con
hartos sueños sueños como los
supersónicos el futuro no hablamos del
futuro y si ustedes recuerdan los
supersónicos que se lanzaron en el 1970
y después fueron famosos del 70 los 80 y
los 90
en visionar en un futuro recuerda aquí
cuando la familia los jetsons los
supersónicos viajan en su dron y hoy
diría los drone son una realidad no
quién más recuerdan de los supersónicos
que ellos en visionario y hoy día es
real
skype muy bien qué más
rutina muy bien claro hay de skype
el apple what's les suena
queman las pantallas plasma hace 20 años
no habían pantallas plasmas no que más
telemedicina simulaciones acabamos de
ver una charla buenísima con todo lo que
es la medicina
telemedicina rutina alguien mencionó
rutina no que más hay por lo que estamos
trabajando quien más recuerdan de los
supersónicos
hay algo que los supersónicos no
lograron en visionar
recuerdan la escuela
si viene dada en un espacio sideral
las escuelas los supersónicos la misma
estructura
la sala de clase pizarrón y un robot la
misma estructura
hoy día hemos estamos trabajando en
méxico en un estado en el estado de
sinaloa
tenemos trabajo con 10 mil estudiantes
allá nos estamos haciendo una evaluación
de impacto y hemos observado que
estudiantes que realizan más de seis
experimentos observamos una diferencia
significativa entre los colegios que
tienen y no tienen el apoyo tanto en
conocimiento como auto percepción del
conocimiento y su motivación por
carreras de stem ciencia tecnología
ingeniería y matemáticas y me tocó
visitar colegios tradicionales que no
tenían la furia igual que robotina y no
un colegio tradicional que estaban
viendo la misma materia de física que
les estaba hablando y luego comenzamos a
implementar el apoyo de los estudiantes
tenían que salir de la clase
experimentar y vivir la ciencia hacerse
preguntas no de las preguntas son más
importantes que las respuestas odio a la
curiosidad y aquí está un colegio con la
fortísima extra primer solución de
ciencia
nosotros creemos que el futuro está aquí
empresas como google spotify que han
cambiado industria über la empresa de
taxis más grande del mundo sin la
necesidad de ser dueña de algún auto o
spotify que tiene una plataforma de
música más grande del mundo pero no crea
contenido de música o herby en vivo que
provee alojamiento pero no es dueña
ningún hotel nosotros creemos que el
apoyo puede ser unas plataformas de
experimentación científica y educación
más grande del mundo sin la necesidad de
tener un laboratorio costoso
si bien tenemos todas estas
oportunidades nosotros creemos que las
buenas intenciones no son suficientes
para solucionar los grandes problemas de
la humanidad sino que necesitamos un
real entendimiento de la ciencia para
solucionar estos problemas de la
humanidad ya sea cambio climático cáncer
problema virus ica etcétera y por lo
mismo queremos que personas sean
pensantes curiosas no para que podamos
fomentar la ciencia y el desarrollo
científico de nuestro país el próximo
ainstein o la próxima marie curie podría
estar en cualquier parte del mundo el
futuro está aquí y el futuro pertenece a
aquellos que creen en la belleza de sus
sueños es por eso que los invito a tener
un laboratorio en el bolsillo y que
puedan experimentar y ver el mundo que
los rodea muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]